SAM: I've yet to prove
myself in the protein realm.
I need to get a fish out of
that river and into my belly.
First thing I'm gonna do
today is check my fish trap
that's way out in the lagoon.
So it's a long walk.
Hopefully there's
something in there.
Anything.
Literally one
crawdad, I'd be happy.
[music playing]
[laughing weakly]
OK, well.
I'm gonna show you what we got.
[laughing weakly]
So if I'm being honest, I don't
know exactly what this is,
but it looks an awful
lot like a leech.
Oh my gosh.
[laughing weakly]
Yeah, it's definitely
they're leeches.
It appears they've been
sucking on this mouse blood.
That's about the grossest
thing you can eat,
is a leech who's been
feeding off of mouse blood.
Bombs away.
I don't even know if
you can eat leeches.
That's probably like the last
thing I would want to eat.
All right, back to camp.
I guess we can haul 'em back
home and use them for, uh--
something.
No fish.
Pretty pathetic.
Another day in paradise, right?
I don't feel super good about
my situation at the moment.
You know, I feel
like what am I doing
wrong if I can't get a
stinking fish out of my river.
Honestly, I feel very down
about not being able to score
more protein at this point.
I thought that
there would be more
stuff out here for me to get.
It looks like fishing is kind
of off the menu for the moment.
And I'm literally starving.
When your wife and kids look
at you, what kind of man
do they see?
Don't want them to
see someone who gives
up as soon as things get tough.
I don't want that.
And so I feel, at this point,
that I will eat anything.
So what we're doing tonight is
we are cooking up the leeches
that we got in the
fish trap that I had
put over in the lagoon area.
Gonna do this even
though I'm not 100% sure
if you even can eat leeches.
Oh, it smells bad.
Oh, I don't like it.
I don't like it at all.
One leech.
So we've got nine
leeches and a snail.
I'm gonna boil 'em for,
like, five full minutes.
I do not want this to be,
like, slightly undercooked
and get some kind of
crazy worm thing in me.
What are the odds
that this tastes good?
Like, I wonder what the odds are
that I pop these into my mouth
and I'm like, whoa, man,
what a tasty, delicious meal.
I'm gonna put a wire
through 'em and roast 'em.
Oh, if this was smell-a-vision,
you guys would be getting it.
All righty, one leech
kebab coming right up.
Bon appetit.
[music playing]
Oh, what the heck.
Let's get these all
four all at once.
I'm still, like, deciding if
I'm gonna throw up or not.
Wow.
[gagging]
Gross.
Ooh, gross.
Yuck.